well i'm surprised because i will say
you weren't maybe so nice on stranger
things i mean do you like playing those
villainous roles i like any role that
has
um
truth
and
complexity um
to it and and this i always saw as an
opportunity for like several different
changes and moments and emotional spaces
to be in and i really enjoy that i
do what i do because i love it but also
because i like to find out what makes
people tick and why people are the way
they are and
i saw this as an amazing opportunity to
do that you know and it's so beautifully
written i mean let's you know let's not
excuse me but
about here like matt and ross are
just incredible writers and and and so
to dive into their world and to be a
part of that was just total privilege
whatever it is um you know you've been
part of pretty big like franchises harry
potter twilight and how does the
stranger things fan base compare to
those this fan base is very funny and
i've noticed that since sort of day one
i've got memes of like vechna arriving
at the met gala
which i thought was just brilliant um
yeah they're very funny and very
sweet and and protective and yeah no
it's awesome it's really cool there
doesn't seem to be any sort of like
toxicity which is nice
i feel weird asking this to vecna but
what would be the song that if someone
played for you that would pull you out
uh
i i it's so funny and i'm so sorry
because i have to answer this the same
way every time because otherwise i seem
like a mad person i mean i am matt but
you know
forgetful um
i if i'm being normal it would be a
placebo
covered running up that hill by kate
bush so i would do that
both of them together beautiful
and if i'm being cheeky and and and fun
it would be miley cyrus party in the usa
absolutely
for the old people who know me from way
back
that's amazing um oh my gosh sorry i'm
processing that because that's a
wonderful answer um you know obviously
we're at the mtv movie and tv awards uh
was there a must-watch
movie or tv show for you in this past
year yeah i just finished watching candy
which i thought was amazing
i loved everything everywhere all at
once was absolutely stunning michelle yo
is a total boss
the northman i love robert
i love that
the eyes of tammy fay i thought
both andrew
both of them just turned in what can
only be described as powerhouse
performances so that was pretty special
i'm yet to see men i want to see men
which is meant to be brilliant i'm yet
to see
the unbearable weight of massive talent
which is also meant to be brilliant so
there's been in the last year there's
just been great cinema that's come out
so yeah oh hard counter was incredible
um yeah just wild stuff
you